bonjour bonsoir le journal de tv 78 pour
un condensé d'actualité locale bienvenue
dans cette édition nous sommes le jeudi
18 février voici les titres
c'est l'une voire la seule activité du
moment pour la profession les taxis
peuvent transporter des patients vers
les établissements de santé les
chauffeurs sont conventionnés grâce à un
agrément de l'assurance maladie invité
vincent comptant un directeur adjoint de
la cpam 78 t'essayes gasmi président de
l'association des taxis saint germain la
semaine dernière l'île de france a subi
une vague de froid en conséquence des
places d'hébergement d'urgence
supplémentaires ont été ouvertes dans la
région 136000 franciliens sont hébergés
tous les soirs quel est le dispositif
dans les yvelines
reportage au centre des mortes mais à
versailles enfin ce sera une nouvelle
solution en matière de mobilité et de
transport les trottinettes électriques
arrivent à saint quentin en yvelines le
service devrait être déployé sur
l'ensemble des douze communes d'ici le
mois de juin
pour ce faire l'agglomération vient de
choisir son opérateur
rencontre également dans ce journal avec
jean pierre garcin l'yvelinois a terminé
tout récemment le dakar à la 11e
position le copilote on est à sa 22e
participation
l'actualité du jour c'est cet
atterrissage prévu peu avant 22 heures
22 heures heure française le rover
persévérance doit se poser sur mars ce
jeudi soir on en parle dans un instant
avec philippe qu'est cud qui le
directeur adjoint du latmos le
laboratoire qui est installé à
guyancourt et on parlera notamment et de
l'implication du laboratoire dans cette
mission et dans d'autres émissions
martienne et mais on va démarrer ce
journal avec ce service dont je vous
parlais dans les titres un service que
l'on connaît seulement lorsqu'on en a
besoin c'est le transport médicalisé en
taxi qui est remboursé par l'assurance
maladie
cela se fait uniquement sur prescription
d'un médecin eléonore sinoquet et célia
gars de son gros ont pu suivre un trajet
avec un taxi conventionné et impatients
regardez c'est à viroflay que saïd gasmi
a conduit son taxi ce jour là objectif
récupérer un patient pour l'emmener à la
clinique de l'europe au port marly
c'est ce qu'on appelle le transport
médicalisé en taxi medica des zus
sous-entendent que c'est un taxi
conventionné
donc en fait on est sous la convention
de la sécurité sociale et donc on répond
à un cahier des charges à des critères
bien précis plus une enquête de moralité
et à partir de là on peut prétendre à
faire du taxi conventionné
c'est à dire à transporter des gens pour
certains soins bien précis pour
bénéficier de ce transport il faut une
prescription médicale et remplir
certaines conditions
pour christian sa dialyse rentrer dans
ce dispositif
moi c'est un traitement qu'on appelle le
longue durée la clinique rempli un bond
transport le bond transports en
indiquant le
deux prises en compte chez moi d'un à
viroflay
et puis leur normalement de la prise en
compte
le soir à la clinique le traitement de
christian nécessite plusieurs trajets
par semaine
allers et retours entre son domicile et
la clinique grâce au transport
médicalisé en taxi cela ne lui coûte
rien une manière aussi de créer du lien
social
je parle beaucoup avec la personne ont
eux tenu du fait que je viens de
pratiquement trois fois par semaine agir
comme un inconnu simple au lit ou entend
se connaître un peu les taxis
conventionnés eux sont rémunérés par la
sécurité sociale
avec la crise sanitaire ce mode de
transport représente aujourd'hui une
part non négligeable de leur activité et
pour parler de ces taxis conventionnés
deux invités avec moi tout d'abord en
visioconférence vincent compain bonsoir
directeur adjoint de la ceppm 60,18 la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie des
yvelines essaye de gaza est avec moi un
plateau bonsoir ansa êtes vous taxis
dans les yvelines artisans taxis et
président de l'association des taxis de
saint-germain-en-laye déjà une petite
réaction sur le sujet que l'on vient de
voir sur la question également du lien
social qui a été soulevée par le patient
vous avez transporter ou là de l'aspect
vital dont on va parler dans un instant
pour votre profession est ce que c'est
aussi important de créer justement du
lien social au travers de ces taxis
conventionnés absolument ça fait partie
du travail
nous sommes taxis conventionnés sur le
département des yvelines en charge et en
collaboration avec la cepam à travers
nos représentants les fédérations qui
discuter des modalités du parcours des
soins parce que tout ça c'est intégré
dans le parcours des soins
donc ça fait partie du travail
évidemment c'est une de nos branches de
notre activité des questions pratiques
avec vous vincent compain qui peut
bénéficier tout simplement d'un taxi
conventionné
je dirais de toute taxe un potentiel
manteau un bénéfice ça passe par une
prescription médicale
ce qu'on est vraiment transport de
malades et donc pour être gagnant
transports il faut qu'un médecin et à
des prescriptions médicales avant le
transport
cette prescription médicale ont peut
être réalisé par un médecin ou d'un
cabinet de ville ou à l'hôpital et le
médecin doit faire établir sa
présélection selon un référentiel de 30
mois les ce retour à sion heureux c'est
au référentiel de transport et se
concentre donc sur des transports au
tour donc pour des personnes qui sont
vraiment dans la capacité de se déplacer
par leurs propres moyens
donc c'est des personnes qui sortent
souvent d'hospitalisation qui
bénéficient de traitements à l'hôpital
on est souvent par exemple sur des
tannins succès national d'accord de
traitement de cancers voilà pour qui
peut bénéficier aussi quels sont les
critères
et avec ces transports médicalisés ces
taxis conventionnés les frais de
transport sont prises en charge par la
cpmc ça oui alors ils sont pris en
charge par la cpam
alors ils sont pris en charge soit 100%
pour des personnes qui ont des maladies
chroniques qui sont reconnus par la cvm
là par exemple j'ai indiqué sur des
traitements transfert c'est une prise en
charge à 100 % mais dans des situations
plus ou moins lourdes on est sûr de
prise en charge habituelle dans 65% et
ont souvent public
est ce que c'est un service très utilisé
dans les yvelines est ce que vous avez
des chiffres nous donner sur le nombre
de bénéficiaires peut être le nombre de
trajets de taxi conventionné aussi les
taxis conventionnés on a à peu près 600
dans l'est dans les yvelines après
peuvent réaliser des courses aussi les
taxes et des autres départements
notamment les dates parisien mais en
tout cas dans les assiettes en taxi et
on a 30 milles environ trente mille
personnes
trente mille assuré chinois qui
bénéficient de transport programmés au
cours de l'année aux 30000 voiliers et
une faction rapporter ou un million on
atteint d'assurer contenu
puis là on est vraiment sûr du transport
de malades sur des pathologies lourdes
on a vraiment une minorité d'assurer
qu'ils en bénéficient et quand ils sont
venus au secours des personnes qui nous
ont fait rentrer au cdja semi je me
tourne à nouveau vers vous à l'heure où
le tourisme est en berne avec la crise
sanitaire ou les voyages d'affaires sont
au ralenti aussi ce dispositif il est
vital pour votre activité
alors il est vital mais il a toujours
fait partie de notre activité
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que l'économie le
contexte économique s'impose à nous et
donc il nous reste aujourd'hui on
travaille en étroite collaboration avec
la cepam je veux saluer monsieur richner
madame c'est un gars qui sont dans
représentants au plus haut niveau aussi
avec monsieur campan ici en
visioconférence parce que depuis des
années ce travail est préparée en amont
alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la crise
sanitaire s'impose à nous mais elle
s'impose à toute la planète est
aujourd'hui compte tenu du contexte
économique
ça représente une part plus importante
de notre activité le ballon bien
aujourd'hui je vais vous dire dans le
contexte précis d'aujourd'hui on est
facilement à 80 soit entre 70 et 90 % de
notre activité
voilà les aéroports sont fermés les
gares parisiennes le télétravail à prix
de la place donc effectivement on se
réoriente complètement vers cette
activité mais parce que c'est notre
boulot c'est le maillage territorial
c'est existait déjà avant et qu'on dit
quelque part le dernier maillon de la
chaîne
si un travail millimétré c'est à dire
quand on va nous appeler ont fait du
porte à porte on est prêt si on répond à
un cahier des charges
donc il ya une enquête de moralité il ya
tout un tas tout un processus qui fait
qu'on répond à la demande à travers la
cepam et ses exigences
et ça vous raconteront bien à un trajet
alors on peut pas répondre à cette
question pour une simple raison c'est
que c'est extrêmement aléatoire qu'on a
des grandes distances
le département c'est un million quatre
cent mille habitants ces 280 de communes
réparties donc les taxis peuvent arriver
du fin fond des yvelines pour aller
jusqu'à paris et là on parle de trajet
peut-être de centaines d'euros et puis à
côté de ça comme le reportage la montre
et on peut faire une course de proximité
à une vingtaine d'euros
si vous voulez on répond
aux prescripteurs après on regarde pas
la tarification des courses c'est pas
c'est pas l'objectif promis
l'objectif c'est de répondre à la
demande des prescripteurs et
prescripteurs ce sont les médecins les
centres hospitaliers entre autres une
dernière question vincent compain tout
simplement quelles démarches faut-il
faire pour avoir ce taxi conventionné
que doivent faire les patients justement
ils peuvent se rendre sur le site
ameli.fr votre liste de l'ensemble des
taxes tricot cie né par l'église
autrement je pense en regardant si elle
fait des sociétés taxi auprès d'elle en
vérifiant saison un conventionnement
avec la cepam il ya à peu près de six
ans donc et compte de nombreuses
sociétés taxi qui attend les yvelines
merci vincent comprend d'avoir été avec
nous au directeur adjoint de la cpam des
yvelines et merci à ces de gasmi a qui
étaient avec moi au plateau je rappelle
vous êtes artisan taxi est également
président de l'association des taxis de
saint-germain-en-laye 6 mars jusqu'à
-10° la semaine dernière les yvelines
ont connu un épisode neigeux mais aussi
des températures négatives une situation
qui a poussé la préfecture a déclenché
son plan grand froid pour disposer de
places d'hébergement d'urgence
supplémentaires
reportage à versailles de mélanie poké
d'eléonore sinoquet les températures
sont aujourd'hui plus clémente avec des
nuits entre 4 et 9 degrés mais au
matelot à versailles le plan grand froid
permet d'accueillir 60 personnes venant
des yvelines de seine saint denis et 2
paris l'intérêt c'est qu'il y en a
quelques-uns qui ont pu effectivement à
la fin de cette grand froid passé sur
une place hivernale puisque nous avons
ouvert dix places hivernales à la place
des places grand froid la halte de
versailles a aussi accueilli dix hommes
isolés supplémentaires la préfecture ne
note pas de pression particulière dans
des centres d'hébergement
les personnes ont été mises à l'abri en
amont depuis novembre
les gammes que nous mettions à l'abri
toute personne qui en fait la demande
donc dans le cas de cette mise à l'abri
exceptionnel on avait aimé faire d'ores
et déjà environ 450 places d'hébergement
d'urgence
on n'a plus le nombre des filles mobile
qui circulent sur le département des
yvelines à la rencontre des sans abri
ont qu à trois équipes mobiles qui
circulent normalement et on est passé à
6 et on a aussi augmenté dans l'eau
liquide horaires pour leur permettre
d'aller à les personnes jusqu'à 5 heures
du matin un millier de places dans des
hôtels ont aussi été créés les yvelines
compte près de 3000 places réparties
dans les centres d'hébergement d'urgence
et je vous le disais en début d'édition
l'actualité du jour c'est cet
atterrissage prévu peu avant 22 heures
heure française le rover persévérance et
doit se poser sur mars ce jeudi soir et
on a retrouvé par téléphone philippe les
cuts bonsoir oui bonsoir directeur
adjoint du latmos c'est le laboratoire
atmosphères milieux observations
spatiales qui est installé à aiguillon
qu'on va parler justement avec vous de
l'implication du latmos dans les
missions martiennes percée avec
persévérance d'abord doit se poser dans
le cratère j'ai zéro et ce n'est pas par
hasard puisque ce cratère a
vraisemblablement eu de l'eau liquide il
y à 3,5 milliards d'années
finalement la mission de persévérance et
de chercher des traces de vie passée sur
mars
oui tout à fait alors fait quatre
missions sucre est d'un grand nombre de
missions dans lequel on a beaucoup
travaillé sur la caractérisation et la
connaissance de l'environnement
cet environnement apparaît comme ayant
été défavorable à la vie et donc
maintenant on va chercher des vieux
tracteurs et donc les missions avec le
rover et et défend principal objectif
il va aussi récolté des échantillons de
mars qui vont être également de près les
prélever et ramenés sur terre ce sera à
partir de 2031 ya une première aussi
philippe picquier culture persévérance
et qu'il embarque également un petit
drone qui est infiniti et qui pourra
permettre peut-être les premiers vols
dans l'atmosphère martienne et ce serait
même une première sur une autre planète
oui du pape et il ya à chaque fois
d'aider l'innovation dans l'équipe
heures un pion à dire que nous on est
pas on n'est pas directement impliqué
auprès des technologies d'ailleurs vous
êtes vous impliqué il me semble sur la
super cam qui est un autre instrument
embarqué sur sur persévérance le latmos
à travailler sur cette caméra mais qui
tapait alors qu'elle est là aussi une
suite logique
on avait travaillé sur les instruments
précédent là on travaille effectivement
sur les aspects de deux spectromètres
qui permettent effectivement de
banaliser le seul mark 1 et donc il ya
des analyses de la roche en compte en
temps réel sur platitude et puis il y
aura aussi comme vous l'avez dit une
collecte de de matière qui sera
rapatriée après coup sur terre pour des
analyses plus sophistiqués parce que
vous l'imaginez bien que des analyses
d'une titus est toujours compliqué à
faire la demande d'un instrument
extrêmement complexes les dernières
choses vous le disiez en début
d'interview le latmos a travaillé aussi
sur d'autres missions martiennes je
crois aussi avec curiosité un qui est un
autre rover qui est sur mars
ce revers depuis 2012 tout à fait alors
part effectivement c'était une mission
qui fonctionne très bien dans lequel on
a là au contraire développer un vrai
analyse chimique qui s'appelle sam et
qui permet la de l'institut d'analysé
effectivement là
la proposition est donc ça va compléter
les observations là avec des
observations beaucoup plus sophistiqué
pour aller détecter toujours plus de de
deux mots l'étude et de et de
propositions du sol qui on l'espère pour
nous renseigner qui vont finalement le
pape et de marbre
merci philippe titude pour toutes ces
explications que vous êtes le directeur
adjoint du latmos arrivée prévue sur
mars pour persévérance ce jeudi soir
avant 22 heures
bientôt un service de trottinettes
électriques à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération a choisi son opérateur
pour la mise en place de cette nouvelle
solution de mobilité et de transport à
l'objectif à un déploiement dès le mois
de juin dans les 12 communes de
l'agglomération les précisions dans ce
sujet de justin brasier
déjà présent à paris lyon bordeaux ou
encore grenoble c'est au tour de sky de
bénéficier des trottinettes électriques
de tir mobility
l'opérateur a été sélectionné pour
mettre en place ce service suite à un
appel à projets lancé par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines en octobre dernier
il a coché tous les critères en obtenant
une note de plus de 18 sur 20 je pense
notamment la sécurité c'est un opérateur
qui va développer des engins avec un
casque qui va avoir des véhicules
à 20 km/heure ce qui était important
pour nous c'est un opérateur aussi qui
sur la partie responsabilité
environnementale développement durable
s'est montré très performant sur le
service qu'il souhaitait déployer et
puis surtout dans la gestion du service
dans la relation client 250 stations
devrait être déployé sur l'ensemble des
douze communes du territoire pour 1000
véhicules
l'opérateur va implanter une équipe sur
saint quentin en yvelines
elle sera en charge de la maintenance du
service et des véhicules
si on comprend évidemment
la mise en place des véhicules sur le
territoire le rééquilibrage également
parce que on veut servir l'ensemble des
habitants donc pour bien répartir
régulièrement la flotte sur les
différentes stations et puis également
une équipe qui s'occupe de ce changement
de batteries la vitesse des trottinettes
est limitée à 20 km/heure elles seront
disponibles en libre service à partir de
18 ans est accessible via l'application
tire c'est aussi là que chacun doit
pouvoir choisir son mode de
fonctionnement donc je vois à l' usage
pour des pour des personnes qui
utilisent peu le service ou de manière
non régulière soit pouvoir bénéficier
des abonnements et les souscrire
directement sur l'application la mise en
route de ce service expérimental est
prévue pour le mois de juin
au total l'investissement s'élève à 1
million d'euros sur un an pour
l'opérateur et 100000 euros de mises en
place pour l'agglomération rencontre à
présent dans ce journal avec un
yvelinois il a terminé le rallye dakar
cette année à la 11e place son nom et
jean pierre garcin le co pilote
originaire de montesson en est à sa 22e
participation sur cette épreuve
son portrait avec michael et demi
d'euros il a brillé sur les dunes
d'arabie saoudite en janvier dernier
jean pierre garcin est l'un des
meilleurs copilotes sur le rallye dakar
cet habitant de montesson est arrivé en
11e position avec son coéquipier
christian lavieille notre objectif
c'était de faire 10 danda karl on a fini
11e voilà on est cependant été 10e et
puis on s'est fait rattraper par un
climat très connue c'est cyril després
annoncé vainqueur moto et c'était pas
grave parce que les moyens n'étaient pas
engagés n'était pas du tout les mêmes
voilà donc on était plutôt satisfait de
la course comme jean pierre garcin et
les courses automobiles cette histoire
commence dès l'enfance passionné de
voitures et de motos que sportif grandi
avec un père garagiste un oncle pilotes
il commence à faire des compétitions
amateurs à 25 ans avant de se
spécialiser dans les 4 4 me mentais ce
n'est dispute son premier dakar en 1996
en tant que copilote
un rôle qu'il ne quittera plus pour être
pilote foire du talent voilà et moi je
me suis
musée pendant longtemps faire des
courses de voitures en amateur mais
j'avais surtout pas le talent alors on
peut tous les tous les pilotes peuvent
faire le dakar c'est qu'une question
d'argent mais après pour un roulé un
rythme élevé et où faut avoir du talent
voilà et donc là je n'ai pas donc ça m'a
jamais effleuré l'esprit
aujourd'hui à 58 ans jean pierre garcin
disputé 22 dakar dans sa carrière une
expérience précieuse dans la navigation
mon rôle c'est lui donner le maximum
d'informations le plus précis possible
dans la voiture à un moment donné elle
l'expérience joue beaucoup quoi parce
que le désert partout dans le monde il
est le même en chine en arabie saoudite
en afrique en australie le désert ça
revient toujours la même chose la
connaissance du terrain il est très
important de savoir ce que le visuel
savoir ce qu'on va rencontrer c'est
primordial cette histoire d'amour entre
jean pierre garcia et le dakar n'est pas
prêt de se terminer libinois pense déjà
à repartir l'année prochaine
le jour où tu en as plus en vite il va
plus voilà ça c'est clair franchement
c'est de cette année ç'a tellement été
agréable que je me vois pas ne pas y
aller
donc on pense déjà comme on va y aller
ça c'est vrai il espère cette fois-ci
finir dans le top 10 un dernier objectif
avant de terminer sa carrière à 60 ans
et puis toujours au chapitre sport cette
bonne nouvelle les championnats de
france de cyclo-cross vont pouvoir se
tenir ce dimanche à lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
il s'agit des catégories à cadets
cadettes juniors hommes et femmes ainsi
que les master's elle les organisateurs
ont obtenu les autorisations
préfectorales pour l'organisation de cet
événement il se tiendra à huis clos dans
le respect du protocole sanitaire et
avec une jauge maximum de 500 personnes
en simultané le circuit long de 2,7 km
fera le tour du centre équestre de l'île
de loisirs voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité demain
vendredi vous avez rendez vous avec le
7-8 week-end pour bien terminer la
semaine de l'actualité des loisirs
également
en compagnie et d'eléonore sinoquet et
de célia gars tsongo belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]